bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono
oggi andiamo avanti
clegg eravamo
praticamente all'inizio di penombra
overture non so che cosa ci faccio qui
sinceramente è persi perché ero caduto
in botta in poche parole una foto
perfetta di questa stanza quasi ok forse
devo mettere la roba come la vedo lì
perfetto ok allora il baule l'omesso ma
è cappottato la sedia pure
e vabbè sono un disastro capito ok
ragazzi siamo manca solo una scatoletta
di tonno
diciamo che la roba è tutto a posto ok
l'unico problema è che era tutto
cappottando a rovescio ok che cazzo
succede è diventato tutto ok
raga siamo tipo in silent hill è
diventato tutto rosso che succede una
foto di non sono certo uova no no no no
no no se mi spunta un ragno anche in
black flag io chiudo la serie qui ok non
vedo nulla perfetto perché il cazzo ci
sono delle mani perché ci sono delle
mani cosa vuoi un secchio tieni prendi
il secchio ok
no no ok allora ci stiamo capendo male
senti prendi telo con questo perché io
non lo voglio
ok montis no non ti schiudere non ti
schiudere montis no no no no no no no no
no no pezzi di merda la frictional games
che ha creato penombra mi sta sempre più
sul culo sacrificio sacrificati giusto
non so non io
ok oddio c'è il cane perché c'è il cane
di overture ma che cazzo sta succedendo
si è andato in volta pesante ok
salve senti ok allora senti io dovrei
andare lì sotto credo lo tieni il cane
perché devo ok che posizione sexy o che
cazzo succede ma che cazzo oddio no no
mi risucchiano che è meglio che mi
risulti piuttosto gara piuttosto che
sale di dentro meglio andarci
ok dove cazzo sono allora piacere fa vj
ok ok si minchia non è che c'era la mano
così calda
ma ce n'è un'altra piacere anche a lei
no forse a devo metterla in ordine
perfetto da una e poi forse questa due
sì poi questa in fondo
ok no sbagliato perfetto o 50 per cento
c'è sempre una sfiga di merda allora 2 3
e 4
ok ci siamo che caldo qui è la rosa e
che lo so c'è una stretta di mano appena
potente credo allora apriamo la porta
prima che ok ok ok sia aperta perfetto
c'è un pieno è un'altra mano ok si è
chiusa con quanta violenza si chiudono
le porte e allora ragazzi siete in tanti
mi fa piacere che vuoi che vogliate che
io vi stringa la mano ma non posso farlo
a tutti
dirò cos'è questo ok si è spenta una
luce inutile cos'è sta roba
oddio che cazzo è ok perfetto non mi
chiedete raga cos'è sta roba forse devo
mettere i barili
ma con che criterio non lo so ok raga e
andato a fuoco qualcosa probabilmente
devo continuare a sposare le di barili
finché quella roba lì non aumenta
perfetto aumentato non lo so se ok ci
sono allora che tocca praticamente rag
alle nuove cucine saranno così non sono
più a gas sono a barili ok
ne manca una fine manca una devo
riuscire a mettere no perfetto questa
era giusto ok allora se due sono giuste
manca soltanto l'ultima che devo
riuscire a metterla da qualche bar ok ok
questo è il nostro posto si è il nostro
posto quanto vuoi ma io apro la porta è
così ci rimani solo tu nel nostro posto
ok
oddio che schifo ma perché è pieno di
sangue ok non voglio saperlo non voglio
saperlo e noi saliamo lo stesso
facciamoci poche domande raga comino
averti poche domande proseguiamo qua c'è
un'altra porta che presumo sia chiusa o
che lì è morto red e che era il nostro
amico di oberto si regge
mi spiace se più felice ora io spero di
sì brutto stronzo e col proteste sono
finito di quando nabe finiamola questa
storia apriamola ok sta salendo sta
salendo un sangue sta salendo ok merda
se ferma bene si è fermato apriamo
apriamo prima che ci non d
ma mi devo tuffare laga
[Musica]
che schifo sono dentro il sangue
fantastico che cosa devo fare qui a c'è
una leva ok
vai dirigerà ospite siamo qui ora ospite
cosa
sono io l'ospite
va beh noi ok va beh noi entriamo cos'è
che succede
ho sentito prima quei rumori e subito
dopo un gran caos meglio scappare
ok e tipo un platform devo riuscire a
saltare su infor che mappa e qualche
ragazzo ok so già che non ci riuscirò
mai raga ma ci provo
vai vai vai poi madonna incredibile il
greco ci posso credere non ci fosse
primo tentativo in teoria forse così i
ragazzi vento secoli ok se sbagliavo
l'ultimo salto era un file assurdo no no
no no no no ho capito cos'è no no no no
no no no no no no no no no
apriti non posso sfondare merda come
faccio a sfondare
ok quei pari a 20 frutto stop se vai vai
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
perfetto ok ma non arriva nessuno amico
dopo il verbone ok mi arriva invece
arriva arriva arriva arriva
ok calmissimi calmissimi svegliati
svegliati si vivo bravo la prossima
volta prendi meno g
cosa ci faccio clienti chi sei tu che
cazzo ne so chi sei se con deficiente
che prende le pastiglie nel momento
sbagliato
his lander comando un obeso è in
penombra comando un impasticcato c'è ma
è normale
ok proviamo ad aprire anche se non so
che è successo
inondazione per a ok così riesco ad
arrivare dall'altra parte è fantastico
però mi sa che prima devo devo prima
posizionarle puoi attivare l'acqua ok
laga faccio soltanto piccolo taglio che
se no ci metto nelle ora riposizionare
tutte le scatole
ok ragazzi teoria dovremmo esserci torno
su di nuovo non sono sicuro di averle
messe giuste però dovrei riuscire a
saltare da una scatola all'altra è
quindi va bene
proviamoci dove la valvola e qui
perfetto
ok vediamo in teoria sì dovrei farcela
speriamo ricordo raga che non ha idea di
che cosa sto per fare a differenza del
primo episodio che invece sapevo
ok ci siamo ce l'ho fatta devo fare
qualcosa qui non perfetto avanti ci sono
delle scatole sì c'è un altro scatolone
norme cosa devo fare qui chiuso cosa
devo fare più i ragazzi uso non posso
andare oltre credo c'è un ok cos'è
quella roba un'uscita mi piacerebbe
andarmene da brigola sai anche a me
piacerebbe andarmene da qui perché come
posso non è proprio il massimo saini
quindi in teoria sarebbe meglio uscire
ma non proprio andare nel bunker può più
andare a casa
siamo in un bagno raga fanta scopo nel
cesso dovevo comparire allora sia con
penombra che con black flag e io direi
che di kakà ne devi fare tanta quindi
prenditi il tuo tempo e falla tutta che
così almeno non ci dobbiamo fermare più
io aspetto
oddio si vabbè senti
fai schifo fatelo dire fai schifo la
bandiera meno lavati le mani non posso
neanche lavarmi le mani ok merda
ci sono c'è allora ci sono delle
batterie qui si perfetto
va bene usciamo usciamo prima di farci
troppe domande dove siamo non lo so c'è
una poltrona fantastica c'è un coso per
salvare ok ok andiamo a di plastik arci
più del dovuto è sempre più difficile da
tirare fuori ogni volta mi sento sempre
più dentro sin abbiamo avuto la prova
prima c'è un bengala perfetto
apriamo tutti i cassetti poi c'è un
altro computer adesso controllo di nuovo
facebook vedo se riesco sebbene il
quadro elettrico sia ruggini the usurato
fare funzionare ok ok adesso non
funziona più questo è sicuro
pare funzionare un paio di palle perché
non funziona
ok ok prova a rimettere un attimo questo
dentro
vediamo se ok fa vige il tecnico chat
video in arrivo oddio mi chiami capelli
ciò che devo fare bella figura perfetto
bagnino raga il nuovo regge abbiamo
annabella se ti senti mai skype che la
gam webcams i fatti vedere
ok o la webcam
raga spero solo di non avere a che fare
con un'altra pazzoidi affitto red però
in teoria dovrebbe questa dovremmo avere
la testa a posto spero alto se gli fai a
di dare giuro che ti presento il mio
amico b e non sarà un piacevole incontro
cattura di sapere vediamo che i sintomi
dell'infezione grazie si è molto gentile
sia da quello che mi stai dicendo io
sono drogato forte io ce l'ho già
praticamente laga in poche parole c'è un
virus che affligge ok abbiamo finito ho
preso un appunto non si sa mai
vabbè abbiamo conosciuto annabella una
vera una gran [ __ ] devo dire e non
contro mio padre vicino che cazzo dici
papa no
ok ok meno male non c'è nessuno vabbè
usciamo di qua infettato mi è venuto un
colpo quando ho sentito con la parola
associato a me eppure sembrava un altro
motivo per trovare mio padre ha già è
vero che io ero dimenticato che lui è
entrato qui per trovare suo padre è nel
primo penombra non l'ha trovato intanto
va beh io spero vivamente che non sia
parente di pif non smentendo madonna mia
ma che impasticcato sei sono una specie
di angelo custode si guarda angelo
custode quello che vuoi ma fammi alzare
allora ci siamo alzati in piedi riesce a
fare più di due passi senza cadere a
terra morto senza avere visioni senza
senza incontrare pif e vabbè o è chiusa
in casa tra comunque sia non entrerò
guarda e condivido la tua idea in pieno
non so che cosa devo fare sinceramente
sono tutte chiuse quindi fantastico ok
c'è una porta qui c'è un po dio cos'è
ho preso l'appunto non si sa mai la
porta che dà sulla biblioteca è bloccata
da uno scanner palmare dalla retina ok
penso che spero che non ci debba a
ficcare la testa di pil in mezzo per
aprirla
anche perché non mi sembra un tipo molto
col doping che legge nelle biblioteche
però vabbè ok ragazzi in ceramente non
so dove sto andando sono tutti i quali
si corridoi machine machine room bene
non so dove sto andando sinceramente sto
dando questo proseguendo a caso questa
roba
ok non posso entrare però non posso
entrare invece
il corridoio che conduce la sala
macchina piena di gas velenoso a quel
cazzo
ok ok ok ok ok non avevo capito perfetto
allora non ci andiamo andiamo da qualche
altra parte cosa devo fare c'è una mappa
sì c'è una porta che aperta che questa r
109 ok perfetto allora entriamo in tanto
qua mi sembra di essere in un villaggio
vacanze quindi fantastico e armory
entriamo dell'armory ok kg la porta si
sa mai
c'è cos'è questo un armadietto si
perfetto un bengala che sembrano mi
sembra un evidenziatore più che un
bengala ma dettagli c'è un materasso non
esiste materasso dove qualcuno non ci
sia pisciato sotto ok c'è un asse una
se.ga mi fa venir voglia di farle famosa
e senti hai fatto un'antitetanica di
recente perché io devo comandare un
malato di mente ragazzi perché perché
devo comandare un malato che cazzo cia
la porta palazzo
porca [ __ ] ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok
ok ok pif ok ok via
ok raga link a questo era pesante mio
dio non voglio più giocare a penombra
perché mi avete votato penombra nel
sondaggio madonna miei ragazzi ma perché
mi date una motivazione ma che cazzo
stai dicendo perché questo parla dei
dinosauri in un momento del genere mio
dio mio dio va bene
raga sentite questo fa continuando a
bisbigliare direi che chiudo qui
l'episodio per oggi veramente ne ho
abbastanza
vabbè se vi è piaciuto vito lasciate un
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come in ogni video trovate
nella descrizione
se non siete iscritti iscrivetevi noi ci
vedevano un prossimo video belle ragazze